bonjour à tous aujourd'hui on va parler
du nouveau smartphone de wons plus le
one piece qui a été présenté par la
marque vous allez voir franchement c'est
franchement une bombe atomique
[Musique]
le monde plus il s'était présenté à
londres il ya très très très très peu de
temps ce qu'on va faire dans cette vidéo
c'est qu'on va faire un tour un petit
peu la fiche technique essayer de
comprendre qu'est-ce que one piece 6
est ce qu'il est vraiment intéressant
oui ou non voir un peu les
caractéristiques techniques et au final
est ce que ça vaut le coup de l'acheter
oui ou non est ce que c'est owen +6 est
vraiment un super produit ou est-ce que
c'est plus un côté un peu esbroufe
introduit bras comme ça qui fait rêver
qui est pas génial en tout cas moi je
peux vous dire que je le trouve je garde
le sud pour la fin nous avions alors
d'un côté fiche technique
j'ai tout là-dessus on va regarder ça
ensemble or déjà du point de vue de
l'écran ils nous ont mis en poche
alors si on avait déjà parlé
précédemment on s'attendait de toute
façon à ce que c'est un coach arrive sur
bonne +6
on voit que les encoches depuis les
seychelles folz et l'iphone disent
surtout sont complètement démocratiser
on les retrouve de plus en plus sur les
smartphones haut de gamme et les
smartphones android
là avec ce produit on est vraiment sur
un produit à cheval entre le haut de
gamme et le milieu de gamme milieu de
gamme mais plus plus quand même d'où le
nom d'ailleurs en plus on a un écran de
6,28 pouces full optique amoled avec une
résolution de 2280 par 1080 pixels 402
ppp avec un ratio 19/9 c'est le plus
grand écran pour puisse trouver chez
fois de plus ils ont gardé le même
châssis que le one + 5 t avec un écran
optimisé un écran beaucoup plus grand
on a un côté puissance un snapdragon 845
cadencé à 2,8 ghz si vous avez deux
versions une version 6 giga de ram une
version en 8 gigas de ram et vous avez
une puce graphique adreno 630 qu'il
gâche strictement rien au plaisir
côté stockage vous avez trois versions
64 giga 128 go ou 256 go leur attention
faut pas se planter
faut vraiment être sûr de ses besoins
parce que pour le coup c'est un produit
qui n'est pas extensible c'est
strictement impossible de rajouter une
carte micro sd pour ajouter de la
capacité de stockage sur de la musique
de l'audio de la vidéo donc si vraiment
vous êtes des gourmands vous filmez on
peut imaginer en cap kablouti beaucoup
de musique beaucoup de photos beaucoup
de vidéos vraiment anticiper vos besoins
et regardez ce dont vous avez besoin
déjà à la base normalement 64 giga on
peut en faire
il n'y a pas de souci alors côté photo
vidéo justement puisqu'on en parle vous
avez un double objectif à l'arrière
situé au centre un 16 mégapixels et un
van heghe a fixé les dates d'ouverture
de f1 points 7 et surtout ce qui est
bien c'est une stabilisation optique
plus forcément très stabilisation
logiciel c'est facile en terme de vidéo
en termes de photos des choses qui sont
complètement complètement dingue parce
que on a beaucoup mieux on va sur le p
23 ans beaucoup mieux sur le samsung
galaxy s 9 plus vous allez voir des
choses qui vont est beaucoup plus loin
en termes de faible luminosité mais pour
faire leurs photos de la vidéo des
problèmes en très bonne qualité avec une
ouverture de f 1.7 vous en défaire des
choses qui sont suffisamment lumineuse
et la stabilisation utile lorsque vous
avez filmé en vidéo ça vraiment faire la
différence à l'avant vous avez une
caméra celle filles de 16 mégapixels ça
fonctionne plutôt bien vous avez le
portrait mode à l'avant comme à
l'arrière à l'arrière vous avez avec le
double capteur donc là vous aurez un
portrait mode vraiment naturelle qui va
être fait vraiment avec les double
objectif à l'avant ça sera fait d'un
point de vue logiciel mais en tout cas
ça annonce d'être plutôt pas mal fut
plutôt beau match tu y arrives vous avez
du hdr pour avoir une meilleure
luminosité pour avoir des ombres encore
plus accentuée un produit qui en tout
cas je trouve de ce point de vue la
photo/vidéo connaissant la qualité comme
et sans vraiment le cahier des charges
doit en plus ça nous aide vraiment top
côté os on a un android et oreo 8.1 avec
une surcouche oxygène aurès en chine
c'est dans les normes actuelles côté
batterie vous avez une batterie de 3300
milliampères heures avec le nash tarn
c'est la charge rapide en une demi heure
de charge vous avez déjà le maître qui
est chargé aux trois quarts bon point
c'est vraiment très précis qui
fonctionne plutôt bien
la po si ti d'avoir une double carte sim
chose qui se développe énormément cette
année de l'usb tisser du bluetooth 5.0
vous avez toujours le fameux port jack
c'est un magicien je dois dire ça je
sais qu'on vienne à qui son soutien qui
ont les casques bluetooth mais moi le
port jack toujours un amoureux des vieux
casque donc je trouve ça vraiment top et
on a un châssis en verre ou tour est en
verre à l'avant comme à l'arrière vous
avez un goal gorilla glass 5 quelque
chose de vraiment solide alors éviter de
me jeter contre les murs a bien
évidemment mais si vous le faites tomber
c'est vraiment quelque chose de vraiment
top
je vous parle et à l'heure du mode
portrait vous avez aussi d'autres effets
qui sont arrivés à vous avez côté cercle
côté coeur côté toile certains mal de
choses en dix points de vue logiciel
c'est vrai que on va dire que one +
soigne vraiment son os sa surcouche on
peut avoir du slow motion pour les
amoureux de la vie
yoland n'attendez pas d'avoir du slow
motion en 1080p avec un super slow nommé
si vous voulez faire quelques petits
effets quelques vidéos souvenirs faire
plaisir et même sur sur le mouche dire
assez classique en 240 images par
seconde mais on va y aller alors côté
tarifs mais temps vous avez trois
possibilités si vous passez sur le
modèle en 6 giga de ram à 64 giga de
stockage
il vous coûtera et vous coûtera 119
euros pour la version 8 gigas de ram 128
go de stockage 569 et pour la version 8
gigas de ram 256 giga de stockage 619
euros s'il vous plaît disponible en
trois couleurs vous avez le mirror black
qui est noir brillant le 1000 mètres
black le noir mat et le silk white plus
dur à dire c'est le produit blanc alors
en produits que vous pouvez trouver bien
évidemment comme tous les autres
produits de bonnes plus directement sur
leur site internet directement dans un
concept store pendant les premiers jours
à paris et pour la première fois on va
pouvoir trouver ces produits
commercialisés directement sur amazon
enfin c'est plutôt pas mal bien
partenariat avec amazon donc vous pouvez
aussi acheter sur amazon si vous avez un
compte chez eux ça peut être assez
intéressant
alors on va que ce produit vient
vraiment très clairement en concurrence
avec des produits tels que le b20 de
huawei tous les produits et je dirais
milieu de gamme on peut aller le
concurrent c'est aussi au samsung galaxy
à 8 de ce début d'année et surtout ses
produits je dirais milieu de gamme qui
vont flirter un petit peu avec le haut
de gamme alors effectivement il va pas
avoir une caméra plus nette si la pas
voir les choses comme ça pour faire la
photo la vidéo de qualité pour avoir
quelque chose qui est vraiment puissant
avec un des derniers processeurs haut de
gamme pour vraiment avoir quelque chose
qui tourne extrêmement bien avec 6 giga
de ram
vous allez vraiment pouvoir vous régaler
c'est un produit vous allez pouvoir si
vous souhaitez l'acheter voulez pas
regarder pendant deux ou trois ans est
complètement dépassé par rapport aux
nouveaux produits qui vont arriver alors
bien évidemment n'avait pas cherché les
derniers gadgets vous avez pas avoir une
caméra avec une ouverture variable de ne
pas voir des choses comme ça ça avec
l'appareil photo le plus dingue en basse
luminosité avec une ouverture de f 1.5
mais pour avoir quelque chose de
vraiment bien dans un super rapport
qualité-prix set up et moi je trouve en
plus de cet écran amoled de 6,28 pouces
est juste magnifique le fait de pavant
augmenter leur et du châssis par rapport
au moins de plus 5 t c'est top d'autant
plus qu'on va avoir cette année un one
plus si c'était ça c'est vraiment cool
on va que one plus j'ai une marque
une excellente grande qualité avec le
one + 4 mais bon pas hyper hyper sexy
loin de +5 pas mal là que le drone +5
tech format 18/9 déjà eu un écran tope
là un écran 19 9e n'ont pas encore plus
loin avec un châssis petit la fameuse
encoches on l aime on n'aime pas on peut
le désactiver sur ne pas l'afficher
attendant on voit qu'on a vraiment un
produit qui est top moi je trouve en
tout cas vraiment super et si vous
intéresse je vous recommande d'y aller
alors si vous avez moins de plus 5 tc
pas la peine d'aller dépenser de
l'argent pour aller là dessus mais par
contre si vous avez introduit un peu
anciens que vous posez la question très
clairement pour moi le one + 6 pour y
aller les yeux fermés des heures dites
nous ce que vous en pensez
est ce que vous pourriez vous laisser
tenter par ce one fut si c'est ce qui
vous botte est ce que vous avez déjà mes
premiers bonne plus est ce que voulait
trouver intéressant est ce que vous
trouvez qu'il voudrait mon sens est ce
que vous pensez comme en tous cas
commandent plus c'est vraiment une
marque tout le monde
on attendait au tournant là très
clairement avec 128 6 ils ont fait une
belle démonstration de force
on va attendre de voir ce qui va arriver
avec 26 t à la fin de l'année et puis
pourquoi pas loin de plus cette année
prochaine
en attendant en tout cas celui là je
trouve cool et d'ailleurs si vous
intéresse vous ai mis un lien de la
description
merci à vous en tout cas d'avoir regardé
cette vidéo fait de lire tous vos
commentaires suggestions interrogations
directement voulu marquer en bas comme
d'hab
cette année c'est des jolies pousse à
vous abonner venez pas me rappelle
toujours eu de tête
il ya plein de choses qui arrivent plein
de nouveautés gens n'y pas plus on reste
connectés
merci à vous et à très bientôt vous
embrasse ciao
[Musique]